what were the kids it's really tough you
know just the other day and my daughter
just turned five you know she was
playing with her cousins and one of the
cousins came to my wife and said Moxie
said God is mean Moxie that's my
daughter did not say God has mean she
said there is no God
one of the older children said oh my god
and she said you shouldn't say that
because there is no God
she's cobbled-together you shouldn't say
that from school where there's no God
from us and it's really hard I think
it's really tough because people I
understand
atheism so poorly I mean the number of
people that say is atheism Satanism
still is remarkable
I mean atheism is as far from Satanism
as you can get Christianity is close to
Satanism at least they some of them
think they're Satan atheism couldn't be
further away it's a little hard and I
think that I am very sympathetic to
people who are surrounded by Christian
people religious people I'm sorry I
surrounded by religious people theists
and have to be a little more closeted
you know I don't believe in I mean I
believe the the parallel to gay rights
is exactly the same I don't want out
anyone you know against their will I
don't even think it's immoral to be
quiet about it it's just not in my
makeup to be quiet about it but my
sympathy I just spend I'm not going to
go into it too much because it's it's
very personal but I just spent a
wonderful dinner with three men who were
acidic Jews pay us the clothes English
was not their first language although
they were born in Brooklyn I never read
a book in English till they were 25
years old and completely within this
religious community their wives their
children their extended families and
they had become atheists and we're
talking to me about
how they were losing their whole
community and their whole families and I
think they expected me to say I think
they maybe even wanted me to say well
suck it up there's no God do what's
right and that was as far from my
feelings as possible I said oh man you
love your children you love your family
you got to keep loving them and you got
to make a lot of concessions for them
and I'm just glad I'm not going through
it and I think that's my answer
to someone who says they're having a
hard time I'm glad I'm not going through
it you know my dad my mom was an atheist
at the end of her life my dad died a
Christian and I loved him with every
part of my heart and I would never have
let religion get in the way fortunately
he felt the same way